[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview first
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with
Christina Patterson journalist and
author and Ali Mirage Economist at the
article so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
well the Observer says some NHS
hospitals with long waiting lists are
promoting Private health care to their
patients
on the front of the Sunday Times the
nhsr to buy beds in Care Homes to
discharge more patients and ease
pressure on a e wards
on the front of the Sunday Telegraph
Prince Harry says he couldn't cry in
public when his mother died
the Sunday Mirror says Royal experts are
claiming Harry has put the Invictus
games in danger after he said he killed
25 people while fighting in Afghanistan
on Sunday Express says Security Experts
claim Harry's book spare has put his
children in danger and that he will be
looking over his shoulder for the rest
of his life
and reminder that by screening the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Christina Patterson journalist and
author and Ali Mirage con list at the
article welcome to you both let us have
a look first of all at the Observer and
this story about NHS hospitals and
pushing the private route as it says
here to quick and easy care to their
patients Christina
well I have to say that there is really
a feeling at the moment that the country
but it most particularly the NHS is
broken at the moment and I think this
genuine Terror that people are going to
find if if they get ill or if they have
an accident that the NHS isn't there for
them on top of the fact that more than
seven million people are currently
waiting on on waiting lists for
treatment operations uh consultations
Etc and what this story is saying is
that at quite a few Hospital trusts it's
very evident that there are fast track
routes available if you have the money
now we know we have a private Health
Care system in this country which people
can use to uh you know jump waiting
lists and that money buys you
preferential treatment and quick
treatment and of course some people are
able to take advantage of that but at
the moment for many people salt is being
rubbed into the wound because they're
going into hospital or they're looking
on their Hospital website and they're
seeing that if they did have 10 000 quid
in their pocket then they could go and
have a hip replacement quite quickly
instead of having to wait months and
months and months as many people are
having to do so I'm afraid what this
story emphasizes is the fact that we are
very much a two-tier system in
healthcare as in so many things in this
country and that for people who can
afford it there are better options but
for the vast majority there aren't and
our NHS in terms of international tables
at the moment is really coming out very
badly
is this simply offering people a viable
alternative to some or is it creating a
two-tier system Ali
well look we do have a GTA system
already
um so there is a private healthcare
available to people who want to go down
that road and can afford it and what
this is actually doing here is what it's
doing is where people are actually
admitted into hospitals they're then
giving them the choice uh to go and buy
their own their own operations in a
private sector if they can to speed up
the waiting list look I think
fundamentally we have a much bigger
problem here and I disagree with
Christina about funding of the NHS we
always have a crisis in the NHS every
year the reason why it's so much worse
at the moment is understandably because
the NHS has been completely overwhelmed
for the last two years with covered
people working extremely long hours in
very difficult conditions uh with
thousands of people being admitted all
over the place and that has led to a
huge backlog and that's why you've got a
pinch point now if you take the number
of people before covid waiting more than
12 months for an operation you had 1300
people in the country you now have over
400 000 people waiting more than a year
yeah and you have a 7.2 million waiting
list so of course they're going to be
pressures in the NHS but to say that we
don't spend on it is just wrong I've
just looked up the figures again just
now will we spend above the oecd average
and we've been spending more
successively for the last few years in
fact it was Boris Johnson who agreed
that four-year pay deal with the NHS to
give them what they are admittedly covet
happened in the meantime so what we
really need is an honest debate in this
country and I very I very much welcome
the fact that we're streating the shadow
Health secretary
has actually said that we need some
proper reforms in the NHS something that
Steve Barkley the health secretary is
also calling for and something that
started driving the former Health
secretary is also calling for we asked
the NHS to do too much we need to have a
proper conversation about what it should
do what it shouldn't do how much we want
to pay and who's going to pay for it and
how and that is the conversation we need
to have all the rest of this stuff is
sticking classes to cover short-term
acute problems which is fair enough
we've got an immediate issue right now
but there's a much much bigger
conversation that we need to have
honestly as a country uh to come to a
conclusion about what we want to do
uh Christina let's move on to the Sunday
Times and this is again another Health
story in the NHS um wanting to buy up
care beds to to clear the wards I mean
are we looking at a dismantling the
beginning of a dismantling of the NHS
Service as we know it do you think
I don't think this is a dismantling of
the NHS I think I think it's welcome
news I think this should have happened
earlier the impression the government
has given has has been that they have
been sitting on their hands watching
this uh crisis implode essentially and
we've heard from many many insiders many
uh doctors Consultants healthcare
workers people like Rachel Clark who
writes widely about who was a doctor in
the NHS and who says things have never
in her experience been worse than they
are at the moment including during the
height of the pandemic I don't think
this is a kind of you know evil move
into private healthcare I think it's
simply the fact that many many elderly
people are taking up hospital beds
because the social care has just not
been available they're um you know
they're stuck in a system the system
doesn't work the social care system and
the NHS are just not properly married at
the moment they they need to be properly
integrated and governments have kept
resisting this because it's all too
complicated and difficult and expensive
I do actually agree with where's
treating that the NHS needs a major
reform I wrote I've had you know quite
bad experience of the NHS even under the
very well-funded days in the labor
government and I wrote then and I
continue to to say that I do think it
needs reform I think the system doesn't
work I think it was
um constructed at a time when for
completely different Health Care needs
post uh post-second World War which were
to do with disease and not to do with an
aging population with chronic illnesses
it's just not designed for that and the
pressures of covid on top of that flew
on top of that and then massive problems
in the workforce due to brexit have just
pushed it to Breaking Point so I'm
absolutely not anti-reform and I am in
favor of this policy of buying up beds
but it's not going to solve the problem
they need to do much more than that Ali
let's move on to another story and
Prince Harry
um still in the news the the headline of
Sunday Telegraph I couldn't cry in
public when my mother died more
Revelations
look it's very sad and we understand
that it must be very traumatic for any
12 year old to lose their mother but
particularly when you have to walk
behind your mother's coffin in the full
glare of billions billions of people
across the world watching you so I mean
I fully understand or I I can empathize
uh with with what Prince Harry is is
saying here but I just think the whole
spectacle that we're seeing unfold in
front of us is deeply unedifying and
we're waiting for this uh interview to
drop tomorrow evening and then the book
is coming out on Tuesday which I Will
Buy and read only because I want to be
informed to be able to comment properly
but from what we're reading I mean so
far we've had the Oprah Winfrey
interview we've had the Netflix
documentary series and now we've got a
book being released that tells us that
both Harry and his brother Prince
William have been circumcised I mean is
that really what we've come to now that
we need to have the sort of details of
every little aspect of of his life um
parade did in this civilized and
undignified manner for us to all witness
I I personally
oh we've seem to have lost uh Ali there
but but Christina pick up because the
Sunday Times is looking at it from the
other side and we've heard a lot from
from Harry but um unlikely to to get any
response from William
well I think it's I mean the whole thing
I just think it's so sad I think it's a
terrible mistake I think Harry will come
to regret having written this book for
all kinds of reasons I think it was
desperately unwise I think to burn your
bridges in that way with the people who
love you most because of course his
brother loves him of course his father
loves him and in any family there are
disagreements but to just write about it
in this way when he knows that William
cannot speak out it's against the code
of the royal family he he's he's
completely silenced it's desperately
unfair and I think it's cruel and I do
of course feel sorry for Harry in losing
his mother and of course he feels that
his mother was essentially killed by the
paparazzi and he feels that his wife has
been hounded by the paparazzi to an
unacceptable degree and I do think there
is something inhuman about the
institution of the monarchy and the way
it is enacted in age of celebrity and an
age of tabloid media I do have sympathy
for that but do I think it's the
greatest suffering in the whole world
when you look at what's happening in
Afghanistan or and you know Ukraine or
almost anywhere you could mention I
think people going who are unable to pay
their bills at the moment unable to pay
their heating bills we'll be watching
someone who lives in a house with 16
bathrooms thinking is are you really the
person who's suffering most in the world
it's just a spirit
quickly Ali aside from the relationship
with his family he speaks about his time
in the forces and Revelations there uh
the mirror is saying that he's made and
the Invictus games a Target another
papers saying that he's made his own
family a Target
well look I mean talking about removing
uh Taliban fighters like uh chess pieces
on a board is hardly what you would
expect from a former Army officer and
look the Army was something that I think
meant a lot to Harry I think his uh
comrades in the Army respected him the
Invictus games on the back of it was a
hugely brilliant initiative from her and
I think he's tainting himself I really
do and I think he's also putting himself
the Invictus games and his family at
risk and that's highly just unnecessary
and dangerous frankly uh to be to be
writing this sort of stuff about
military operations in Afghanistan in a
book okay Ali and Christina thanks very
much for the moment we are going to take
a break coming up this story in the
Observer teacher strike could close most
schools uh more on that and Other
Stories when we come back
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Christina
Patterson and Ali Mirage welcome back
let's have a look at the Observer and
another potential strike in the offing
most State schools across England and
Wales will have to close completely on
several days in February and March if
the country's biggest teaching unions
vote for industrial action this week
Christina
yes now a National Education Union
um is going to ballot its members about
a strike and if members vote they need
to reach a threshold of more than 50
percent then that will mean a strike in
schools and other unions might vote to
join in and that means that pretty much
every member every whole area of the
public sector would apparently be on
strike in this collapsing country so I
mean I'm not a parent and I will not be
personally affected but it really does
feel I I do remember the 1970s I do
remember having to do my homework by
candlelight and that whole feeling of
the country being on its knees and it
really feels like that again uh it's I I
just hope things get better it's hard to
see how the government are going to
navigate a way through this because they
don't want to give pay Rises that are in
line with inflation because they think
it will push inflation up they want to
give give them much much lower than
inflation but that means in that means a
real terms drop in pay for public sector
workers who've already had big drops so
it's hard to see how this will be
resolved yes the National Education
Union general secretary Kevin Courtney
saying that uh he's confident that those
who vote in the ballot will be
overwhelming in favor of strikes so more
misery potentially ahead Ali or all
those parents who will have to take time
off with their children not in school it
just uh snowballs isn't it
yeah it reminds us of what happened
during covid and we're already in a
situation now where so many kids up and
down the country are trying to catch up
uh from all the lessons that they missed
encoded and what happens in these
situations is yet again those that have
the resources uh be it in terms of iPads
or technology at home and also parental
support will do better than those who
don't and that is the problem that we
face and it's just going to increase the
Divide even further so this is
absolutely
just a horrible news I do understand
obviously that people want to get a fair
pay raise I fully empathize with that
but I just don't think it should be
inflationary we can't embed inflation in
the system we want to try and get it
down it's predicted to go down this year
in any case but it's certainly not going
to if everyone's going to ask for
inflation busting pay Rises so yes both
sides need to get around the table it
needs to be sensible but it can't be
inflation uh at the level of inflation
or inflation busting in my view because
we need to get on top of inflation
otherwise we all suffer Christina just
take us to the Sunday time
is heading for Davos this is a is this a
first for a labor leader
um I don't know but um I don't know if
there'll be any snow there either
because apparently there's no snow in
Europe at the moment or very little but
it certainly shows that how things are
shifting and that labor wants to
establish itself as the pro-business
party and Rachel Reeves who will become
Chancellor if lead wins the next
election as I hope they will and the
polls currently indicate they will is
being widely quoted actually by business
people so um yes this is definitely a
shift in tone and I think uh kirstama is
trying to kind of study the horses and
show that that labor will be you know a
kind of steady responsible government
who will be in favor of growth after the
disaster of Jeremy corbyn and so far he
seems to be doing a pretty good job of
that definitely wanting to highlight
that labor is the party of a business
that's the message they want to get out
Ali and Christina thank you very much
for the moment we'll see you in the 11
o'clock hour thank you